World of Warcraft has been blowing up on
twitch lately and there's one guy who's
pulling in viewership numbers that are
absolutely nuts
oh so bill does mr. bordelles new rule
his name is osman gold and lately he's
had more eyes on him than shroud and dr.
disrespects what's up y'all
guess who that's right it's me mr. boy
asthma going so it's been a hot minute
since this many people gave a [ __ ] about
World of Warcraft see nostalgia is a
funny thing
that can keep people stuck in the past
or hating something just because it's
new you look at we go so this is
basically BFA so we'll look at BFA
compared to Burning Crusade okay this is
the this is the comparison am I wrong
and asmin gold is a perfect example of
this that means people bought storm outs
you spit on those [ __ ] because
they're ruining the goddamn game like
these [ __ ] idiots keep buying storm
mounts oh wow I can't wait for Blizzard
to bring out something else with my
money so I can pay for it again now that
well classic is dominating twitch he's
reaping the rewards
but who is asmin gold and where did he
come from well back in the day he gained
a cult following from twitch and YouTube
for being kind of a dirty boy here's my
desk you know my character [ __ ]
awesome it's a streak warmer colors I
probably have 30 McDonald rings here
some might say he's obnoxious loud and
elitist which you could chalk up to the
character he plays up on Street bunch of
haters well no people just complain
about me all kinds of vote for all kinds
of [ __ ] like who cares I mean honestly
if I'm making somebody mad like that
it's probably a good thing and his chat
has been described as a total minefield
one of them says something like type
type 1 2 3 gay in chat and then like
they all type 1 2 3 gay
I enjoy streaming I really do but it
seems like later at night like I have I
don't have idiots on a stream
be real that's what it really is now
Aspen gold has never had a problem
letting people know how he feels about
blizzard that means in a three-month
period they've lost over 1/4 of their
entire subscriber population you know
the only real question I have to ask
here is is anyone really surprised does
anyone really surprised whenever people
decide that they're not gonna pay money
to play farmville anymore
most streamers help most people have
changed a lot since 2011
not asthma gold he is the exact same
person he has never once cared about his
self-image only about the content
despite this Osman gold has come to
represent a large and vocal part of the
WoW community ok and so I'm happy I'm
excited we're gonna be doing a live
stream the day that the announcement
happens like I'm gonna be going in so
hard like I'm so happy it's 9:00 in the
morning so that's good for me cuz I
probably still be awake by that time and
for years that part of the community has
wanted a proper revival of vanilla well
I don't really know if how help how hard
it would be for them to redo but I
personally would really play and I know
I I think that personally you know if I
was not playing
I would probably subscribe just to play
that in 2017 a full two years after his
initial pitch rumblings of a WoW classic
began to circulate I want to talk to you
all about official Wizard legacy servers
here we are boys er denounced vanilla
servers alongside their new expansion
battle for Azeroth this is something
that I've been wanting something that
I've been pushing something that I've
been advocating for for over two years
and the following year asmin gold and
his community got some pretty good news
I don't want to say that I told you so
yeah I do I told you so I knew it was
gonna happen look at this man
I [ __ ] knew it dude I knew it was
gonna happen it was a [ __ ] fact now
that while classic is finally here it's
all asthma Gould wants to play and it
seems to be paying off in September
alone he gained nearly a hundred
thousand followers and picked up more
views and watch time than shroud and
doctor disrespect combined there's no
doubt that Wow classic has been in
tremendo to that success the old guard
is returning to relive their glory days
and newer players are getting the chance
just to see how different Azeroth used
to be granted servers are packed and
there's enough connection issues to fill
one of asthma gold streams but the
upshot classic Wow is back and it's on
top and Blizzard has the rabid fan base
to thank for that
[Music]
yeah not only that but asthma Gould is
holding a $40,000 duel tournament in
while classic we will be redoing and
bringing back the dueling tournaments
and on top of that there were a lot of
people that thought this tournament was
really really good there were even some
people that thought it was so good that
they're probably gonna give us 40
thousand dollars in prize money to give
out for these tournaments to begin with
nostalgia is funny fickle but ultimately
it's a pretty lucrative business what
the future holds for WoW classic is
unclear but for this one beautiful
moment
World of Warcraft fans seem united again
yes dude alright boys this is it this is
it we've been waiting for a long time
it's taken some time it's taken a lot of
time but we are finally [ __ ] here
let's play classic [ __ ] Wow and Asthma
gold is a big part of that thanks for
watching if you want more content like
this hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite-sized
videos you won't find anywhere else hit
up our Instagram Twitter and Facebook
pages
you